[Music]
hey
we're back once again yeah i'm sober
yeah last night was something else man
i got i got pretty loaded i just walked
off the show you did it make sure
[Laughter]
i would normally not eat on the screen
because i think it's gross but
yeah but i was pretty drunk and i made
the tacos for myself
i didn't come back i just you and she
went she had to go get me she's like uh
you're not coming back
[Laughter]
it was over anyway from what i remember
the show was over
what you remember i said yeah and
somebody said go check on punk i said
yeah good idea
check on pokey and i'm getting something
to eat i walked off and
i already had i already had tacos
prepped so it was only like a couple
couple minutes to do up the meat and
then do the uh do the do the tortilla
you know heat up the tortillas and just
made them yeah you know
i kind of remember that yeah they're
good you're sitting there and then you
just kept talking
and then you had i went and looked at it
this
is all right but you kind of forgot that
the show was off
you're just kind of yeah oh he'll be
back i guess
you're reading what people are saying
but you're not reading you're not saying
out loud what it was they said to you
that's all right i'm just kind of like i
used to
i guess i used to worry about it and
like sometimes i'd wake up in the middle
of night going oh [ __ ] i don't remember
like
if i finished the topic or whatever and
i did wake up in the middle of night
because i had to pee and also because
pookie jumped on my chest
like she does going hey just checking on
you are you awake yet are you awake yes
you are
okay and then um but i woke up and i was
like nah [ __ ] it
i'm sure it's fine whatever
you're in there talking everybody thinks
it's funny when you get that everything
that was funny
yeah i thought it was pretty funny too
yeah i've been uh
listening to this new band he just
showed me this you guys yeah
you guys might like it it's taken me
back to my teenage years man
it's [ __ ] old classic metal but it's
new it's a new band it's called
eternal champion
[Laughter]
it's good it sounds kind of like a cross
between
iron maiden man of war and ozzy osbourne
yeah i thought it sounded a little i
sound like ozzy's like black sabbath
yeah kind of like black step not
but uh every song is about heroic
[ __ ] like that
and he's a he's a barbarian he's a he's
a fighter pilot he's a [ __ ]
dude in a war he's just whatever he has
to be at the moment in each song
and that's why he's the eternal champion
he's a champion for all time across the
multiverse
yeah he's even an alien it's the same
[ __ ] but he's a different
character
in every song and as soon as it was
explained to me that way
i was i immediately knew i said okay all
right
i accept that like i said i admire their
commitment to their thematic
kind of overarching theme there because
you could kind of you could kind of um
say that about iron maiden that it was
all about the same dude
every song was the same guy just in a
different setting he's just doing
different
just playing a different character yeah
yeah well you know so i was like oh okay
yeah that's it right there
but yeah check it out if you if you're
into and and
the genre is called epic metal
sure and i which that's the first time i
heard of that but i was like oh of
course i know exactly what you're
talking about i put that [ __ ] on it's
[ __ ] epic
okay like yeah that's absolutely truth
in advertising that's epic
[ __ ] metal eternal champion
yeah i love the cover of that album that
you showed me yeah it's like real low
budget barbarian
very frank rosetta looking kind of yeah
it's like a knockoff like a knockout
yeah frank frazetta done with [ __ ]
colored pencil
sure with what it looks like to me yeah
kind of actually looks like the [ __ ]
cover artwork from a dnd module from
back in the 70s it does that's what it's
that's what it reminds me that's what it
looks like
thank you yeah yeah all right so uh
we're doing a movie review today this is
a movie that we watched a couple
nights ago uh it just came up on shutter
it's a shutter original
and this is a south korean movie called
lingering now i think that the original
title
was hotel lake which actually makes a
little bit more sense than lingering
does
but whatever you know they just changed
it this is the korean
shining this is it is very shining-esque
and i'm not really sure is it only just
like the shining
because it's set in like an abandoned
hotel
and there's a room that's kind of cursed
or it just has a very
kubrickian yeah kind of except it's much
warmer it's not like
it was imagine if the shining was korean
and it was a giallo flick
sort of yeah it had kind of a color
palette from
from it actually it kind of had a 90s
color palette it was a beautiful looking
movie
i mean like the framing and stuff like
that and i think the um the person that
directed it
uh who i think their name is kim yunin
this might be their first
movie so not a bad job gotta say like i
said you know the cinematography is
really nice and [ __ ] like that
so basically what the story is um is
that there's this girl
named uh you me and
she's like in her 20s i guess looks like
and i guess her mom dies and she has
this
little bitty sister it's either her
sister or her half sister i'm not
uh i don't remember but she's like way
way younger she's only like six or seven
so she basically uh has to take
responsibility for this little girl
and she's not too jazzed about it
because i guess
um you know she doesn't have a job she's
kind of you know she doesn't have a lot
of money and she's kind of having her
own [ __ ] and she i guess she was kind of
um
estranged from her family prior because
you know they
she thinks that mom committed suicide or
had mental illnesses and she's afraid
she might fall in the footsteps of blah
blah so there's like this whole thing
so what she does is she takes this
little girl she picks her up from the
orphanage and like the lady at the
orphanage i love how [ __ ]
blunt the lady was basically like this
kid's defective i don't know if that's
the word she used
but she said something to that effect i
was like wow that's nice
but um so she takes the little girl from
the orphanage
and she goes to this kind of remote
hotel that her mom's best friend owns
and i guess it's not abandoned but it's
off season so it's like there's nobody
there it's like it's
you know the the woman that owns it is
there and there's like one maid
but that's about it like a couple people
that come in and out
and just like in the shining there's
like a haunted room in this case it's
405
and um you know ghostly things
ghostly hijinks ensue and also there's
kind of a mystery with
what really happened to like who this
ghost is what really happened to
uh the girl's mom in this hotel and
various other things so like i said
this is it does have a lot of homages to
the shining like a lot of the shots
are you can tell they were kind of
referencing that
and just you know just these long you
know hotel hallways with like little
girl like the creepy room and everything
like that it's not exactly like it but
you can tell that they're kind of like
amazing
um you know like i said the the
cinematography is really beautiful the
framing of the shots is really beautiful
like i really really like
the set design the production design is
really really good
um i will say very early on and i'm not
going to spoil it if you haven't seen it
but very early on there was a really
good i don't want to call it a jump
scare
necessarily um because it wasn't like a
hey big ghost in your face type of thing
it was just like a really
it was really quick it was like a second
but it was like just this great
like the shocking unexpected imagery
and when i saw it i just went like that
and like i don't do that
like when i watch horror movies i missed
it i was looking away at the time and i
was like
oh my god that was great yeah um just
because i didn't expect it
yeah um so i will say that it had one of
my phys like i said i don't want to call
it a jump scare because it wasn't like
ah it wasn't like that
but it was just like an unexpected
moment and i was just like wow i really
really like that
um and i feel like that was kind of like
the best scare in it i will say that
this movie
is it's definitely a horror movie and
it's creepy and there's ghosts and stuff
but it's a lot more of like it's pretty
subdued and it's a lot more of like a
drama
it's like a little slow a little bit
like it's like a family drama
like with occasional ghost activity i
kind of
yeah i liked it it's just that it was a
little slow
and my mind started to wander a couple
times the story was a tad
convoluted i had a hard time following
the story
it's a little korean in the way that
they did things and korean
korean writing is sometimes kind of like
japanese writing let's say storytelling
korean storytelling is like kind of like
japanese storytelling
it's not quite in the same three-act
kind of
situation as it is in western stuff it
kind of meandering
well and it's you really have to pay
attention to like every conversation
you're not really sure what's important
or what isn't and then all of a sudden
something happens you're like why'd that
happen it's cause you really weren't
paying attention you know what i mean 15
minutes ago or something that happened
but i did like the tone all right it's
set in a hotel
that looks very abandoned and it's kind
of octagonal and maybe about seven
stories tall
but it doesn't look very big around and
it's got a like an abandoned parking lot
outside of it it's out in the mountains
it took me back to korea i mean used to
see stuff like that in korea
just some building like what the [ __ ] is
that
and it did look they would look
abandoned you're not really sure if
you're looking at a government building
is that an apartment or is that a damn
pump house or is that part of the water
department the [ __ ] is that
because some stuff in korean
some of the stuff in the korean
architecture it's now
back in those days it wasn't real
recognizable to a westerner you weren't
sure what
kind of building you were looking at
yeah the way they built things
and you can tell this really is an
abandoned location from from at least
the outside the exterior shop that they
showed you and used to see that [ __ ] a
lot
down there so it kind of took me back to
that
and you could tell that was some funny
architecture it's
not the act the base of the building
which is octagonal is not very big but
it's kind of tall
almost kind of like a like a small
version of the leaning tower of pisa or
something
um then you get in there and you find
out it's like it's a hotel with like an
octagonal central
open space with halls that go around and
there's rooms on the outside of it
and when you can look up it looks big
until somebody looks over the [ __ ]
rail and you realize how small that
internal space is
you can see why it was it it didn't look
like it would be
uh an ideal business you know i mean
business layout it was looked a little
small for what it was
yeah um but what it did was that it gave
the movie a certain tone
it reminded me of something like one of
those dead mall videos
it did kind of have that feel time i
really liked
urban exploration yeah i really liked
the because i mean the hotel didn't look
like shitty like it wasn't like falling
apart or anything like it still looked
like it was an okay shape
um the shapes though the colors of the
places were a little weird
yeah and you know is that korean koreans
had a weird way
of faking western architecture too like
some of the clubs we used to hang out
with they would try to make that [ __ ]
look as comfortable for us as possible
you know make it look western right
yeah so they'd have down old west wagon
wheels and [ __ ]
in it [ __ ] hanging from the ceiling
mixed with something else like from a
a scene from something out of holland
[Laughter]
so you're like wait a minute hold on i
got it it's all western
yeah it's fake old west like 1950s old
west
mixed with [ __ ] the little dutch boy
and you know i mean in mexico
they didn't know what what was what they
didn't have any cultural
contact context for this [ __ ] and he
used to see some of that stuff in in
architecture some of the new
architecture they would make it would
look like a cross between
korean and western mixed with
i don't know tacky sometimes just some
tacky [ __ ]
and they think that would look real
[ __ ] sophisticated but you're looking
at a massive tacky [ __ ] right there you
know
and so that's what you're seeing and you
saw that in that architecture right
like you know what i mean the the things
over the doors that were
the arches are kind of strange shaped
and
it's just the way koreans used to do
things i think there was
a 90s build that building yeah it might
be like it was
90s and and i was there in [ __ ]
19 1991 and 1990 and there was a special
version of 90s
korean tacky you know you just see it
and that was kind of it right there
yeah yeah better better than usual
though that was that was supposed to
they had kind of dressed up like it was
a an abandoned high-class hotel
at one time you know yeah that had been
pretty good for
korea especially that area that they
showed that was out
somewhere near near [ __ ] engine gack
is what it looked like
rolling hills up almost in the north
yeah i'm not i'm not really sure
i don't even think they said like where
it was supposed to i guess it didn't
really matter because like other than
the beginning where she picks like her
little sister up from the
orphanage pretty much the whole thing
takes place in the hotel right i don't
think there's any
as you go north in korea as you start
going to the northern part of south
korea
it's it just ends up being rolling hills
nothing but just rolling hills
and rice paddies and flat areas you know
i mean in between the rolling hills
and the further north you go the more
jagged and the steeper those hills get
that's
that's usually how it goes yeah so that
was
that was around somewhere like around
camp that was that was north of camp
casey
that's what it looked like terrain wise
north of camp casey
yeah yeah but yeah this was i mean it's
not doing
anything uh revolutionary in the asian
horror
milieu if you want to like be snotty
about it it does it
it has like a lot of the same you know
tropes that
you know other korean horror movies have
had that other japanese horror movies
have had you know you got your
you know long haired ghost like with
long black hair and
it you know kind of creeps around and
pops up in the mirror every now and then
but that said um
if you kind of like more slow burn kind
of gothic
sort of more drama mystery like with a
little bit of ghostly [ __ ] in it
um you know it's worth watching i think
it's worth watching i really liked
there was just something about it that
was really i guess it was like the whole
environment like i really liked the look
of the inside of that hotel and like
just
the the feeling that it gave you while
you were watching it so it's like even
during the parts like you know in the
second act when it was like slowing down
a little and i was getting a little bit
confused as to like what was going on
um i was still like interested to see
what was
happening just because it was so cool
looking you know what i mean
also i gotta say the little girl that
was in it was great i do you know what i
mean i don't
a lot of child actors maybe not so much
nowadays but a lot of child actors are
kind of you know they're annoying or
shrill or whatever but she was
actually she did a good job and she was
adorable also sandra says
who who clicked the thumbs down sandra
don't worry about that [ __ ] man
whenever i start talking they see me
they're gonna click the thumbs down
because i'm [ __ ] pretty man because
i'm [ __ ]
serious and [ __ ] thumbs down
[ __ ] that guy
that's what they are doing
maybe so yeah it ain't easy being pretty
i wouldn't know
it's okay she said jenny would either
handsome
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we have pizza and i'm just like oh thank
you manco
thank you for those who remember last
night so not me
thanks man this is for burt reynolds in
the cannonball run [ __ ] wait i
remember we talked about burt reynolds
right yeah so he complained that you
guys you know i like what you guys do
there's too many guys go off
topic oh yeah i saw that earlier i said
man we used to keep this show to a tight
one hour
one hour time limit but people liked it
better
when we relaxed it up relaxed the time i
feel like yeah
people so you know our regulars like it
when we just
and we stick to the topic but we're
gonna i mean
most of the time but yeah we're gonna
give you some sidetrack [ __ ] man i'm
gonna get sidetracked on something and
then we go back but
you could learn all kinds of interesting
things you could be watching a show
about some completely unrelated topic
and then bam
there's a recipe for meatloaf well most
peop most people you know they got
headphones on
they're trying to get some sleep or
they're driving a truck or they're at
work
i mean they got they're trying to kill
three hours i know the deal they do the
same thing
yeah i mean [ __ ] when i'm just when i'm
working in here and just want something
to like
zone out to in the background i'll put
on like some of those
channels that have like three or four
hours of like just people reading scary
stories from
reddit or something like that i found
one the other day that does like 10 hour
ones
i like urban exploration and like dead
mall videos
and you know retail archaeology you know
like kind of stuff
just something that's got a good
soundtrack and just showing you yeah
because they have like all that
vaporwave in the background and usually
like oh
most of your main like dead mall videos
like dan bell and
um sal who does
like they have like really relaxing
voices yeah
so you know relaxing soundtrack in the
back yeah
well like i said that's one of dan
bell's videos that had that olivia
newton-john song in it that was that was
what inspired us to watch zander's view
the other day
just because of that [ __ ] song that
was playing in the background
because it makes me sound all distant
like it wasn't really in a mall
yeah and i like seeing those old
buildings you know i mean there's a
little
mall interiors and [ __ ] retail
interiors and they're just all
vacant and abandoned and it's like
you're seeing something that was
like a part of you growing up you're
like you could have never would have
imagined that something like that would
go away
and they're just showing you yeah this
shit's old now and
it's going away like standing next to
the grand canyon or something
yeah you know what i mean like yeah
everything comes to an end
so i like it i like it it's kind of like
a weird well they're kind of spooky
which i like about it
yeah although the weird thing about it
is that dan bell he also does videos
where he goes to like straight up like
abandoned like creepy ass places like
[ __ ] old
hotels that have like crackheads
squatting trying to see if there's
ghosts in him
trying to see if there's ghosts in him
he's so cute like he's trying to like
[ __ ] he's like
what the [ __ ] was that he's like
pretending he heard ghosts and whatnot
but weirdly i don't find those as creepy
as the ted mall ones
yeah that doesn't make any sense what
one that gets me is like
he'll he'll sneak he'll sneak video of
the dead mall on the inside and it looks
[ __ ] perfect but it's like most of
this
most of the spaces the retail spaces are
[ __ ] empty
and you'll see these old people doing
the walks around the mall mall walkers
as well
and he'll [ __ ] record the mall
walkers and
it's [ __ ] creepy because you got a
dying maul and a bunch of old
people walking around and and [ __ ]
the dad's [ __ ] with him about
yeah he's walking off to his bright
future
[Laughter]
dude dudes in his [ __ ] late 70s and
you're saying he's got a bright future
and [ __ ] [ __ ] yo
maybe i think you're dying just like
that damn mall maybe i think the
dead mall videos are creepier because
when you go
like if you do urban exploration you go
to a place which is like abandoned or
has been abandoned for a long time and
it's just like you know falling to [ __ ]
and it looks like there's [ __ ] mold
growing on everything
like you expect that to be empty but i
think like dead malls because
a lot of them look like
still kind of brand new like especially
i think the creepiest ones are the ones
that still
look new like they haven't been you know
they haven't been abandoned that long
and then there's just nobody in there to
me that's like creepier
than like a place that looks like a band
that's been abandoned for a long time i
don't know
that's from uh svet from bulgaria say
giving us a thumbs up saying he's a big
fan
what's up all right we got people from
all over the world
all over the world deep deep
in the hunky motherland deep in the
hockey motherland that's right
oh my god oh man
all right um i i need a nap yeah but yes
so
that's all i told tom i was like well is
he talking about old man nav i said i
need an old lady nap today not
not usually but today i do yeah i think
i think that
i think the dead malls are videos are
creepy when the mall like you said
is in pristine conditions yeah that's to
me like creepier
yeah one of the ones that was dying was
just [ __ ] totally empty it was
it was a brand new mall it's only eight
years old it was like the last mall
the last maldives yeah they built it
like fairly recently like as mall
construction
yeah it was eight years i think it had
only been there for eight years
at the time that he recorded it but that
was probably like five years ago
but that was like the last mall ever
built it was beautiful pretty much wood
floors
totally empty nobody in it yep we knew a
place like that that's we did a podcast
from
from a mall like that remember [ __ ]
got the old gods and monsters
yeah yeah there's a big beautiful mall
it's gone it's torn down yeah you know
that
yeah and they put a damn amusement park
in the middle of the mall
yep or not with a music park what do you
call it like a big
like a big obstacle course yeah you
could crawl across it
it didn't attract anybody um
are there many abandoned malls in the
u.s there actually there are quite a few
um i don't know how i don't know how
many there are offhand because a lot of
the dead mall
channels that you see like some of them
go to the same ones
yeah but because some of the ones that
are like kind of famous
but um not all malls in the us are dead
i mean before the pandemic we had our uh
you know altamonte mall which is not too
far from us that's where we used to go
to the movies
yeah that was um i think every
store front was occupied still yeah i
think it still had
all or most of its anchor stores yeah
and it was usually pretty busy
yeah the problem was that the anchor
stores that keep those places open we're
all closing
yeah so i don't know how it's doing that
may not even be there anymore we have to
go back and look at it
and then once the anchor stores are gone
they're the ones paying the rent
saying paying the most rent paying the
most rent to keep them all
air conditioned and once they're gone
you can't really air condition the thing
for very long and people start leaving i
mean some of them
they've been able to convert into like
say office space
yeah but even that's going away but
because
retail office retail excuse me what do
you call it uh commercial
office uh commercial office real estate
is [ __ ] plummeting
in most of the country so it won't well
yeah i mean since
most people have been transitioning to
like work from home like working
remotely so
but if you want to see what we're
talking about um you want us
you want to go on youtube and go look
for dan bill yeah
dan that's the name of the channel dan
is it just dan bell or this is dan bell
might be this is dan bell but you can
just put dan bell dead mauls and his
[ __ ] will come up
because he's kind of the best known yeah
he's the best one and you can watch
watch his entire series you can just
zone out
and it's kind of like everything's very
retro everything's very nostalgic it's
like what it was like growing up in the
80s and the 90s in the united states
when when malls were the main way we got
our our retail products came from malls
all replaced by cell phones now you just
you can't compete with cell phone and
amazon you just just can't
yeah well the prices and the selection
are so much better and i
i order it and the next day it's at my
front door yeah it's like you can't get
any easier though
and it saves you money on gas and it it
sucks because it puts everybody out
of a job but that's
that's why technology increases you
don't see people shoeing horses much
anymore
you don't see people making carriages
you don't see people running [ __ ]
steam engines
churning butter you don't see people
churning butter much
you know although i bet it's good a lot
of that yeah i've made butter before
but cream just keep whipping it yeah a
little bit of salt wait and it'll turn
into butter it's really good
um it's got to turn into whipped cream
first and then it yeah
boom collapses into butter like magic
yeah it's really good
but uh doing it by hand would be a [ __ ]
though
well yeah but uh yeah it was just
another time i don't know how old you
are sven but
that was how we got our [ __ ]
he goes yeah 19 america rocks he's
looking at the champ
it 1980s america we were there at the
time
and we thought it was [ __ ] really
[ __ ] high attack back in the days but
you look at it now
and [ __ ] man it was like six hundred
dollars for a [ __ ] shitty color
television
yeah eight thousand dollars for a really
shitty [ __ ] american car
you look at the architecture and the
clothes and it looked very [ __ ] we
remember what it was like trying to shop
there just wasn't any selection yeah the
you know you'd have people talk about oh
man this capitalism
this and that it didn't seem like
capitalism
it seemed more like the soviet union it
was
yeah you had to pay for [ __ ] yeah but it
was very bulk
very the products were very very generic
and there were a lot of them and it was
kind of like a top-down
kind of supply chain that was forced on
you
you went to the store and this is what
you have to buy and only this this is
all you have
yeah like you couldn't find any goth
clothes or
you'd have to go to some special shop
like out in new york
or you have to mail it you have to mail
order it we used to mail order stuff
you know so it really wasn't until
the mid-90s you started seeing online
shopping and
and a good selection and choice and that
[ __ ] felt height
high tech as [ __ ] first time i bought
something over online
i felt like i was in a damn the running
man from arnold schwarzenegger man
when he bought that damn airline ticket
over web tv
what it was like i had a web tv it was
blowing my [ __ ] mind
i was shopping at hot topic over the
television
it was [ __ ] trip and other people
couldn't grasp what i was doing
that works and i said yeah it works and
i did it with an atm card
which was kind of like a new thing it
was
we called it a bank card yeah back in
those days
and you couldn't use it at a store you
could only use it at an atm to get cash
and then you used cash to buy stuff in
the store yeah i remember not being able
to use it you couldn't use it at the
store
at the store you could use credit cards
you could use a credit card that was it
you couldn't use an atm but i used an
atm card to pay for something over the
internet and that
that somebody saw me do it i don't
remember what it was and it blew their
mind
you're like what is it yeah i bought it
with my [ __ ] bank card oh my gosh
it's like the [ __ ] jetsons all over
here
that's a [ __ ] heavy-duty [ __ ] man
it's really weird i guess
well i guess because it just happened i
mean everything happened like naturally
and organically so it wasn't really
yeah it's really weird like how
incremental like
how different it is nowadays but since
it happened in small increments it
wasn't like a big shock or anything you
look back and it's
you know technology just built up built
up built up now it's just collapsing
the technology that we have is
collapsing huge sectors of the [ __ ]
economy
uh retail retail [ __ ]
um um
retail real estate and commercial real
estate for offices and stuff it's just
cities cities are going to be going to
go obsolete because there's no real
reason for a city like it used to be
you'd have to move to downtown new york
to do online to to
to do to do to work for some kind of
banking firm
you're making 700 000 a year well you
can do it from home now and you can live
in mississippi and do it working for a
new york firm
in mississippi in your house you know so
you don't need to spend seven thousand
dollars a month for your high-rise
apartment
you know what i mean [ __ ] you could
be somewhere in laurel mississippi
paying 400 a month for a [ __ ] mansion
and have five cars and a private
helicopter
because you'd be able to afford a
private helicopter
so in a way it's kind of getting more
efficient it's cutting out a lot of
middlemen
but the problem was a lot of those
middlemen were part of the economy but
you know what [ __ ] them a lot of those
middlemen
were in banking and pharmaceuticals and
they didn't really do anything
they just had this position where they
could grift off of the flow of money
they themselves weren't anything
important and um they're losing their
[ __ ]
i'm kind of glad about i'm happy because
they were stealing basically
they didn't really have a purpose they
repair people always saying you know
these people at the bottom of society
these poor people are like parasites
no there are more parasites up at the
top
well yeah a lot more parasites at the
top
i can't afford to be a parasite
that's either basically our political
class they're just [ __ ] parasites a
lot of them don't they don't have real
jobs
they got fake jobs they get grift
grift and bribes and kickbacks selling
off the power of their office
all that shit's gonna all that shit's
gonna get exposed over time people know
people know what's going on
yeah people know what's going on now you
just
and a lot a lot of what they're doing is
legal it's just that they're they're
gonna be cut out of the chain
by technology eventually that's what i
think will do it you know what i mean
because what they're doing is
technically it's not illegal technically
well some of it is but a lot of it isn't
illegal
but technology will catch up with them
yeah
yeah um okay so
like i said i need a nap um
[Laughter]
so if you have shutter and you're into
asian horror
and anything i said about this movie
lingering sounded great like i said it's
not fantastic but it's
it's worth watching you know what i mean
i thought it was like a pretty decent
movie
nice to look at had a couple nice sort
of jump scares in it that i thought were
pretty cool
good acting so you know your mileage may
vary
so whatever all right so we will be back
tomorrow
doing another movie review i got a
couple lined up that i will probably
watch on hulu this evening
and uh then we'll talk about them
tomorrow so we'll see you guys tomorrow
thanks for dropping by
bye